je viens d'avoir la libye s'inquiète
beaucoup pour leurs ambassadeurs eh bien
il faut le faire rentrer bon écoutez moi
tous s'il vous plaît il me faut une
liste d'au moins dix noms de sources qui
pourrait en pâtir
si ces télégrammes sont publiés compris
si on peut affirmer qu'assange a du sang
sur les mains
on retourne la situation
salut à ton avis le président du
turkménistan sera plus vexée que je les
traités de menteurs que j'ai osé le
traité de bayonne
on a dû dire bien puis le président
berdymouhamedov ne tolère pas les gens
qui sont plus intelligents cru car il
n'est pas très malin il doit se méfier
tout le monde il a dit au pouvoir assez
longtemps pour ne pas se préoccuper de
l'opinion d'une attachée aux affaires
étrangères c'est pour ça que j'ai des
signes et hillary